uh magnus what are your comments about  this the candidates tournament and jan's  performance in particular  he's playing very well uh he's  making the most of his his chances like  uh  there have been many interesting games  but he's uh converted all of his  advantages very well uh and saved bad  positions so he's been by far the best  yeah i mean did you expect it to happen  no i didn't expect it i thought he was  um  criminally underrated by um  by pundits and and betting odds but i  still thought  that dean and fabiano were even bigger  favorites but kudos he's done really  well  is it going to affect somehow your  decisions to play the metronome what do  you think about it now we'll see yes  okay thank you very much for your  comments